das is a monolithic and ruthless group  masquerading as a group designed to  liberate women  i was just thinking like where are we  how did we get here  this has to be stopped  i heard keith hasn't been seen for weeks  i'm pretty sure he's on the run  keith rainier is charged with sex  trafficking racketeering sexual  exploitation of children  by being able to do the most distasteful  of activities  you're going to be the agent of change  imagine you spent 22 years trying to  build something  and everybody thinks it's the devil's  work people didn't stay because they  were coerced they stayed in it because  they really thought they were making  society and the world better that's just  next level  this intent was never about doing  anything good for any woman keith is  very dear to me and i know he's innocent  do you know the best way to train a con  artist  let the games that they play work  [Music]  you